capra capra se vuoi essere una capra
ecco come si fa premier per fare la
popolazione dire premier per fare la
stessa cosa adesso la devo vedere
ragazzi che non capisco il senso cosa
questa merda adesso voglio premere r
giusto per scoprire la novità del secolo
proprio meraviglio è poesia posso che
fare sulle altre capretti cioè che bello
assaggia e tristezza della madonna cioè
questo ragazzi stato il vero significato
di lasciare un amico nella merda c'è
proprio sarebbe questo se dai mangia che
è tutta salute forza ex scusa mise a non
volevo che tutti ragazzi e benvenute
nessuno video sono fa vj ci sono tanti
su gerrard simulator che negozi che
sarebbe quello da mode con gli zombie o
con i forchetta ri quelli con le
forchette grossi ingrossano questi
ragazzi non sto capendo più vado avanti
e p non lo capisco ma è la meraviglia
proprio fatta videogame più creazioni ma
sì che c'erano un miliardo di cose che
non ho fatto alla fine quindi devo farle
assolutamente tutte perché voglio capire
è stato l'anno ma non avevo notato
quanto fosse bella la capra cosa vado a
fuoco perché ma dopo da capra è
l'emblema degli zombie sono dai fuorché
una capra sei un [ __ ] che cazzo
succede di armi e mica sono già morto
lega sono morti sto morendo sono morto
quanto di gioco 30 secondi sono già
meraviglioso ragazzi questo significa
giocare ai videogames d'accordo ragazzi
era accaduto tipo madonna che che volo
fatto mi era accaduto tipo un
approvvigionamento dal dal cielo ma non
sono riuscito a prenderlo male dice
vabbè dai sarà per il prossimo comunque
fatemi capire cosa devo fare che che
cazzo sto finito e tanto faccio st
croazia che non capita eccola qua ci sia
una prima cosa che voglio fare ragazzi e
non in modalità difficile perché già non
riusciva in modalità facile è questo che
mi hanno detto che e wipeout che sarebbe
tipo un programma dove bisogna saltare
gli ostacoli
io conoscevo takeshi's kastel che
secondo me è imbattibile nella storia
però va bene anche questo cipro 3 2 1 ok
primo ostacolo è fatto il secondo non
sono morto perfetto solo una merda devo
mangiare un attimo ragazzi prima di
partire perché devo avere lei
energie le forze dato c'è una morta a
terra nudo l'anno stuprato probabilmente
forzano inizio dai cioè capitana e il
bello è che la modalità facile questa
abbastanza di quella difficile mangiato
un cervello perfetto ma bastava stare
bassi ma [ __ ] e ditelo prima ma
allora siete bastardi nel cervello cosa
fa cosa cazzo stai fa e io ci ho fatto
anche il bagno qua dentro
sì ma che cazzo ci sia un idrante
ascolta fratello è mike bravo fa l'ha
dentro perché se non è che si può stare
così maleducazione e tanto e anche a
tempo sta stronzata sia the view non
riesco a farlo senza tempo fiore del
tempo ai a malori dos c'è uno con un
sacchetto che mi sta sputando naba
affanculo guido bastard di morire vi
faccio pisciano addosso guarda che c'è
conoscenze io è perfetto ragazzo trovato
una cazzo di cassa per dopo anni male
vizi a caso tra a un medico fantastico
che cazzo è stata valeria c'è un sacco
di farina cosa mi serve a lancia la
farina ma perché quello si sta in
trippando col paracadute bellissimo
amico mio beccati questo è un attimo
giusto per capire è la madonna sono un
kill mickey è bellissimo ragazzo o la
farina e non ho paura di usarla madonna
una tragedia faccio delle killah assurda
allora adesso decente
e allora sei stronzo nell'animo sentite
[ __ ] non sono fatto per wipeout
ragazzi mi dispiace avervi deluso ma
[ __ ] tutto però non è possibile a
farseli esclusi ma c'era anche di qua
amica si vede che ho fatto quella
difficilissima come ho fatto a finire
qua sopra non doveva andare così credo
bellissimo robert kubica non ce la farò
mai più nella vita li fa sta cosa
una sedia che galleggia ma chi se ne
fotte vai avanti forza dai che sei forte
dai questo è difficile come in salvo
come mi sono salvato perché non lo so
neanche io ma va bene così guarda lo
ebbe completa il percorso ostacoli senza
toccare l'acqua veramente mi sono fatto
il bagno giusto 16 volte ma va bene
uguale cazzo fa quello si sta
masturbando la cravatta ma [ __ ]
che botta o da non regga ma io io lo sto
amando sto gioco ci abbiate pazienza è
bellissimo che cos'è sta roba riga ci
sono persino le giostre ma bellissima
ragazzi noi non usiamo le scale io
faccio climbing sul muro adesso devo
solo saltare da una parte alla prima
perfetta per chi sono io so farle queste
cose c'è bisogno c'è uno scivolo della
madonna che a guardarlo mi viene male
devo farlo assolutamente no no ma
sociali aver scala e ve lo giuro finché
la capra va lascialandà che sconta
fratello non tentare il suicidio ancora
che devo fare lo sci vocazioni
applaudito ed io invece di applaudire
sappi che tua moglie si sta trombando 10
capri insieme se salvando è morto
se stessi dato così va bene mi dispiace
guarda che stava mentendo è troppo tardi
va bè ragazzi devo fare questo giro
incredibile prima di morire vai sono
mica che tempismo che non va a fan culo
eccolo che minchia cessalto della
madonna perfetto c'è un parà caduto
cazzo cazzo
l'ho preso l'ho 6.000 della madonna come
come è possibile non ci crederò mai se
ci riprova un miliardo di volte non mi
riusciva mai più c'è da un chilometro di
distanza sono riuscito a dare l'epicità
l'epicità assoluta da chiodo ragazzi se
l'uscita di tornare dove era la scotta
zio e tornatene da tua moglie che hai
capito bene che si sta diventato una
caramella rai mi dispiaceva buttati giù
che è più bella la vita è vivo se è
ancora vivo
come fa a essere vivo 3 2 1 bello bello
tirato una craniata la partenza è stata
bella ragazzi perfetto dai cos'è ragazzi
cè un cazzo no no no no non l'ho preso
[ __ ] non l'ho preso c'è una mira
di merda va bene nei porti che ha messo
un bersaglio in mezzo all'oceano non mi
faccio domande re che ormai siamo in
grossi mulè tor quindi non mi faccio
domande che facciate voi è che non lo so
cosa faceva ascolta zio c'è un tregua
così è caduta ma no è caduto un tizio io
rischio no non riuscirò mai a un circo a
cosa se non so cosa l'hanno messo a fare
ma non ci arriverò mai nella vita per ok
qua invece sì mica che salto fatto qua
cioè non potevo farlo prima con
creazioni va da un'altra parte perché
sono ancora curioso di capire cosa devo
far kicks medico a ragazzi c'è un'altra
isola ma mio zio che figo scotta zio
sempre mi dispiace ecco bravo torna da
me sta scusi guarda scusami ti giuro non
volevo non vorrei essere inopportuno ma
dove cazzo ti stai leggendo in piedi
palermo che ha la chance
volevo andare a vedere un attimo l'isola
dell'ultima volta perché lo villa v
vista ma male perfetto portato al colo
portato al gol importante questo che
l'importante è portare l'alcol sono un
[ __ ]
ok ragazzi ci sono di nuovo perché
nicchia non è possibile che non riesca
col culo per aria dovrei riuscire ad
arrivarci si spera che cos'è stanno
attaccando la città gli alieni come se
non bastasse l'epidemia di zombie
perfetto c'è mica la guerra dei mondi
una figata pazzesca regatante ragazzi in
posizioni comode complimenti sono
saltati una balena è stata una balena
farci saltare sa cosa non lo sapevo
pensavo fosse stato lo so la rampa
[ __ ] ma perché la barca rimane
suio porca [ __ ] no silent hill
perché c'è silent illing simulator non
l'ho capita sa cosa che mi sono
arrampicato al contrario come comunque
ragazzi volevo dire che l'ultima volta
che sono riuscito a passare di qua avevo
creato una roba strana che hanno capito
manco io voglio provare a ricreare ramis
ore prima un businessman che va a fuoco
meglio molto meglio così almeno è bello
cotta a puntino passo alla buona
aggiunge l'ingrediente segreto eccolo
qua perfetto cos'è sta roba premi r per
rimpicciolire le teste ascolta zio dove
rimpicciolirsi la testa ma che cazzo è
ma non si vede la testa cioè non e
maschere si stronzi non ho ben capito la
gunn cosa state facendo cosa è un
sacrificio umano rega ma [ __ ]
mandato a cagare tutti è volato un tizio
che non ho pagato di striscio prego lato
con cannes corano non capì cosa stanno
facendo si struggle simulator con
portati da capra ma solo una chiave
ragazzo scavata zia devo comportarmi la
capra quindi devo far finta di essere
una capra attiva di essere mia amica
questo sarebbe un [ __ ] [ __ ]
l'organo ditemi che non è vero o
rimpicciolito la testa ad una capra è
bruttissimo terminati voglio vedere
questo questo fenomeno come
rimpicciolisce bellissimo vabbè è la
smetto di rimpicciolire teste a capre
vado avanti green screen studios che
figo no vabbè dai veramente devo trovare
tratto sono sopravvissuto quasi quattro
giorni non è mai successo starò la pro
key words larghe st holst toast più
largo del mondo così cambiata la visuale
ma corre da perché in diretta tv raga
immaginate tipo cotto e mangiato che una
capra che entra fa casino ecco io
guarderei la tv che bello una capra che
manda [ __ ] tutto non so e la tizia
eppure morta quindi audience al massimo
grazie è stato bello sono una star no
vabbè geniale rica sono morto per chi mi
è venuta addosso una cup ma lui ma devi
essere la star dello show è arrivata
tardi istanza riccardo ragazzi concluso
fine episodio di gas simulator ho
cercato di guardare più cose possibili
perché la mappa è veramente enorme c'è
una cosa pazzesca
mancano ancora un casino quindi voglio
vedere poi cosa diavolo gli scatti da
fuori però per ora va bene così ring
ragazzi se il video è piaciuto la solita
lasciato sgomento mi piace anche a
pagina di facebook e come non i video
trovate la descrizione se anche a voi è
piaciuto il concerto dei thirty seconds
to mars che ho appena tipo distrutto lo
stand di chi sa che calcio hanno tirato
a quel christian veroli mi piace che
mettete uno strumento nuovo a questi
gran ragazzi che sono in grado di fare
musica e di keke che ritmo che già nel
sangue quel tizio sull signori si
discute cm ci rivediamo nel prossimo
video bella ragazzi avete finito non
avete finito un cazzo perfetto da
ragazze